good morning i literally woke up like
this
today i thought that i would make a day
in my life video
it's goes to sushima embargo day so
that's where we start because i'm not a
morning person i immediately wake up and
start working
food comes later so let's do it okay i
saw the light i actually absolutely do
do my skincare and brush my hair first
[Music]
all right i look like a vaguely
presentable human
also here's my knee i like honestly
spend
most of my day working with my knee up
on my pc
sometimes it makes it in the videos it's
very exciting so i start off by
um editing inside gaming daily brian who
is our
lead writer for insight gaming starts uh
early because he lives in texas
thus is several hours ahead so it's
easier if
we kind of start our day jumping into
brian having already
uh started but this is one that we
agreed on last night too it goes to
tsushima day so i messaged ryan i was
like i think tomorrow we should cover uh
the ghost of tsushima reviews no matter
what they are so
um i get to basically jump into his
his story that he's already started and
make some edits and add some stuff
before we record the daily promoter who
doesn't know
youtube.com inside gaming we do a daily
video game news show and this is how it
[Music]
works
[Music]
recording alana for a while i thought it
was ghosts of
tsushima and and there are different
ways to pronounce
tsushima i think i'm pronouncing it
wrong but i just keep doing it
but basically this is one of yes
tsushima anyway basically this
is one of the big ips for playstation
that we've been looking forward to for a
while and it's almost here it releases
friday the review embargo lifted early
this morning
most critics liked it we actually are
doing our own little
impressions on it so look forward to
that all right the daily is done it
takes us
maybe like 30 to 40 minutes to record
upload it it gets edited it gets
published at
usually around 4 p.m pacific time um i
now have
i think like 15 minutes before my next
thing which is a stream also for inside
gaming where we're going to be talking
more about ghost of tsushima
and then i jump straight into a podcast
and then i jump straight into another
stream
but i realize that a lot of this footage
is literally just going to be me
sitting at this pc so that's the job
that's my job
you know what i totally forgot that i
was smart enough to make myself
a smoothie yesterday um and i left it in
the fridge so i actually
do kind of get to eat breakfast right
now
i have five minutes before i have to
jump to the next thing
i'm gonna have a smoothie this is greek
yogurt cinnamon peanut butter
some protein egg whites and water but
it's actually like
delicious it mostly just tastes like
peanut butter and yogurt
okay let's talk about more video games
on the
internet alana's gonna talk about ghost
to tsushima i am going to merely be a
sounding board
because i haven't played it but you have
i have
yeah i've been playing it for about two
weeks now
um i have the chat open so you guys feel
free to ask any questions you have
from the jump i want to say uh
this is one of my favorite open worlds
in any video game ever
um and i feel like that's a pretty big
deal so the open world is just crazy
crazy crazy pretty i'm not a person who
really spends that much time
in photo modes but with this game
specifically i just could not stop
taking photos okay that's another stream
done uh i now have another 10 minutes
until my next thing
so i did finish my smoothie though
that's exciting i'm gonna make myself a
coffee super quick
and then we record play watch listen on
a tuesday for anyone who doesn't know
that is my uh games industry play card
games industry podcast with uh
austin wintery troy baker and mike
bithell and this week we talking also
about ghost of tsushima it's a very
ghost to sushima day for me today
um mike your webcam looks really bad
quality
it doesn't matter though if you can't
fix it it won't be a problem you know
what it is
you're very pixelated i think kerry's
calling her friend in the next room i
don't know
uh phone call we'll get you it doesn't
matter it's not a problem i just thought
i'd
give you the heads up what happened mate
there's two windows that pop up i was
like well i don't need that other window
up i just need this window up
and so if you close that section window
yeah
that is a thing that happens what an ass
beating that is
okay no break this time i'm immediately
jumping into streaming awk with fun
house
they're actually already live so i just
jump in they just call it and then
launch the game and join them basically
who's that who it's me oh hi
and i i'm watching you on the stream
lindsay to like try and get an idea of
uh what this game is and i saw you just
[ __ ] flying on the back of a dinosaur
and was like i'm sorry what
yeah oh yeah it's well it's that kind of
game you just came dinosaurs
you throw
how to get on the server okay
um oh my god
so we streamed uh
recorded play watch listen and then i
immediately jumped into
streaming arc for fun house
um which is also part of my job uh but i
downloaded the game through game pass
for pc
not through steam because it was free
which i guess means that it's not
cross-play with other pc the epic game
store and steam across play and then an
xbox
and xbox game pass for pc or cosplay
so that didn't work so i just kind of
hung out while they streamed it
uh yeah we stream them every tuesday
from 12 to two
pacific time doing shoots back to back
from nine am to two is a lot i don't do
that very often i usually get like
at least a bit of a break in there uh oh
also i've mentioned this on
on instagram and stuff the reason my
face is always really shiny
is not because it's sweaty um but for
the record it is pretty hot it's because
all i really do in the morning is put
moisturizer on and that just leaves me
very shiny for the rest of the day i'm
just owning it now
it's good for your skin it's whatever
don't worry about it now i can finally
do something that i find extremely
enjoyable for whatever reason
ah put the green screen down
it's like getting rid of the little
caves that i worked in
good stuff more space slightly
i'm gonna make myself some lunch so
let's do that i've been defrosting some
chicken
boom lunch we have uh apple juice mixed
with sparkling water
uh well i mean there's chicken under
there under a fried egg i'm into it
it's probably not a lot of people eat
chicken that way but i love it some
broccoli and
some hippies chips just for the side
yeah it is so hot in my apartment right
now and my air conditioner
this [ __ ] right here doesn't work uh it
never has not since i moved in and it's
the worst so
sitting in front of that pc all morning
and then making food
that is also hot which is my bad really
it just makes this place get very hot
very quickly because my apartment is
very small
so this is the point in time where i
open my windows and i put my hair up and
i try to cool down a little bit
but my day is not over yet yeah i can't
record the windows open because it's way
too noisy outside
it sucks i feel like my neighbors would
also just hear everything which i'm
weird about
but next up i need to watch the stadia
conference which also happened today
uh because we're making a feature for it
for inside gaming later this week
kaden is working with me on that she
sent through
a dock that i'm gonna have to take a
look at after i watch the conference and
then i have to test a game
for a fun house gameplay and then i
think i might stream
and then probably play some ghost
sushima and then go to bed
oh i need to work out at some point too
hey guys back in the exact same spot we
were earlier i just don't have my green
screen up
i decided i'm just going to stream the
stadia conference it's only 18
minutes and 40 seconds so i'm just gonna
stream it because why not
maybe leave it up on youtube i don't
know and then i remembered i actually
also have an announcement video
that i have to film today because
tomorrow we're announcing that i'm
joining the kind of funny team
um we're gonna be doing up an xbox
podcast for the next six weeks so
stop to be a part of that it just you
know keeps occurring to me more and more
that this is really not
an a visually interesting vlog
because you know my apartment's tiny and
it all
really just takes place in this one room
for the record i really like my
apartment
it's just really small but i like it
here like if it means saving me money
which it does i'm also okay with it
being small
oh hi what's up
is it free games hang on hang on why did
you make that that fast
is it because there are all games we
haven't heard of
why was that that quick
okay he did say free games that's good
news
all right i did a stadium live stream
real quick i made a video to publish
tomorrow
i looked over my notes i mean cadence
notes all right
change my shirt gonna work out today
it's beat saber
um obviously this is gonna look
ridiculous because vr looks ridiculous
but i tend to like i have weights here i
have some resistance bands and ropes
and stuff i do beat saber and i do some
supernatural vr
to get claudia and today's beats save a
day so let's do it
so that's pretty much it for that uh i
play 45 minutes on expert and just go
through all the songs until i get good
enough that i can finally do expert plus
i have to get really sweaty it's hot in
here so now
i'm gonna have a quick shower and then i
have to test out ooblets
and battle arena ooblecks we're
streaming tomorrow for inside gaming
battle arena we're playing friday i did
already play that
but that was pre-release so i want to
make sure that i understand the full
release version
basically i'm not going to take you into
the shower with me so i'll see you back
here
all right i'm back it is ooblet's time
um this is actually a pretty significant
part of my job is testing out games so
ooblet's a really easy one i'm just
making sure this runs because i want
most of the gameplay to be fresh for
inside gaming tomorrow
rocket arena i'll probably need to play
around with a little bit more and i'll
do that right after this
just to make sure i understand how the
game functions and make sure there's a
functional party mode and stuff because
sometimes
i'll think for fun house that we can
play a game and everything's gonna work
just fine and then we try and it falls
apart so
i learned that lesson um i do spend yeah
a fair amount of time testing games gta
maps because you play games i've sold a
multiplayer all the time now
or just like with a single player game
sometimes picking the right spot so
i played around with the last of us part
2 and ghost tsushima for a while
and then i'll i'll save all the time and
i'll just pick a place for us to play
um for the fun house gameplays which
always record for an hour so
i try to pick a place that doesn't have
a lot of dialogue for uh
when we record those but yeah uh for a
time check
it's almost 7 p.m right now so i'll be
testing these two games
after i'm done with all this i think i
might stream a little bit of the
premonition and then i'm going to make
myself some dinner
and then i'll probably play ghost of
tsushima and go to bed so i actually
think that i might wrap this up here
i hope this was interesting to you guys
at all just kind of wanted to give
people an insight to what my
regular day is like in isolation and i
guess also just what a day is like for
someone who works professionally in
video games so this
is that i'll leave links below to where
you can check out all the content that i
recorded
today otherwise thank you guys for
watching i'll see you all next time bye